quelques minutes de patience pour vous
soumettre les questions que nous avons
imaginé première question êtes vous
favorable à l'abrogation de l'actuelle
réforme du collège voulue par le
gouvernement deuxième question êtes-vous
favorable à l'autonomie des
établissements scolaires impliquante
aussi un vrai rôle du chef
d'établissement en terme d'animations et
de recrutement des équipes dirigeantes
etes-vous troisième question est doux
favorable avec la réévaluation et de la
rémunération des enseignants en
contrepartie d'une augmentation d'un
temps de présence au sein des
établissements pour la réussite des
élèves
quatrième question êtes-vous pour
l'application du principe de laïcité sur
les bancs de l'enseignement supérieur
public ainsi que pour les accompagnants
scolaires cinquième question jugez-vous
nécessaire de mettre fin à la réforme
des rythmes scolaires sauf opposition
des acteurs locaux dont le maire sixième
question êtes vous favorable à la
suppression des dispositifs
d'enseignement des langues des
communautés d'origine pour permettre une
meilleure intégration de tous les élèves
7e question êtes vous favorable à la
création de classes de cp plus pour
permettre un suivi renforcé des élèves
en difficulté
concernant la lecture 8e question êtes
vous favorable à la suspension des
allocations familiales pour les familles
en cas d'absentéisme et de refus des
règles de l'établissement
9e question à l'image de ce qui existe
en outre mer êtes-vous d'accord avec la
généralisation d'un service militaire
adapté pour les décrocheurs âgées de
plus de 18 ans dans le but de les
réinsérer dixième question êtes vous
favorable à un acte ii de l'autonomie
des universités pour refondre la
gouvernance améliorée la sélection des
étudiants et donner plus de
responsabilités de gestion aux
universités voilà à vous de répondre et
merci à tous